it is Halloween 2022 and you're watching
the code report the number one goal of
every JavaScript framework developer is
to make the world a better place the
second goal is to make tons of money
unfortunately this almost never happens
except today remix the react framework
was acquired by Shopify for those that
Don't Know Remix is a framework similar
to nexjs from the team behind react
router while it only has a small
fraction of the actual adoption of next
JS it's been highly influential in the
react ecosystem like many of the
features announced in next 13 last week
appear to be inspired by features and
remix like nested layouts although one
could argue that these features have
been around forever in PHP Frameworks
and elsewhere what's interesting though
is that less than a year ago Shopify
came out with its own react framework
called hydrogen like nex13 hydrogen uses
react server components which is the
react team's official solution for a
server-side rendering remix on the other
hand takes an entirely different
approach that doesn't rely on react
server components now that Shopify is
taking over stewardship of remix it
creates this weird Schism around
server-side rendering and react like do
react server components totally suck or
are they the future Shopify said quote
while we're excited for the future of
RSC long term as a critical dependency
it presented a number of challenges that
became performance risks for our
developers and bottlenecks for our
progress and they also talk about how
they want a clear separation between
client and server code that makes total
sense for Shopify which has built itself
with Ruby on Rails which has a strong
separation of concerns it looks like
their plan is to replace server
components with remix over the coming
months but remix will still remain its
own independent open source project if
you're a remix user I think this is
definitely a good thing Shopify although
its stock is down 75 percent the last
year is a great company that will battle
test this framework on their platform
react server components though are being
battle tested by Facebook whose stock is
also down about 70 percent the reason
the stock price is important in this
context is because restricted stock
units are a big part of compensation at
both meta and Shopify and that just
feels kind of demoralizing for the
people who are employed to work on these
Frameworks full time on top of that it
seems like in 2022 people are becoming a
lot more open-minded about alternative
Frameworks like svelt solid and quick
looking dank AF right now but only time
will tell if they can become goaded with
the sauce in fact I chose spell to
overreact to rebuild the fireship pro
website recently and I have absolutely
no regrets the website is smaller faster
and most importantly it was just way
more fun to build in any case react is
not going anywhere anytime soon and this
is just the latest chapter in The Great
JavaScript framework War this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one
[Music]